je souhaite que nous travaillions main
dans la main pour définir une politique
de soutien à la ruralité
nous devons notamment avancer ensemble
sur notre planification écologique
pour cela nous avons mis des moyens sur
la table j'avais annoncé dans un premier
temps la mise en place d'un fond vert à
hauteur de 1,5 milliards d'euros puis
qu'il serait abondé de 300 à 500
millions d'euros supplémentaires je vous
annonce aujourd'hui que la moitié de
cette enveloppe supplément
supplémentaire soit environ 200 millions
d'euros sera mobilisé pour les seuls
départements ce sera l'occasion de
financer des projets ciblés locaux
notamment dans les territoires ruraux et
je vous confirme que nous ne procéderons
pas par appel à projet dont je crois que
nous sommes tous un peu lassés et que
ces crédits seront déconcentrés au
préfet
mesdames et messieurs nous avons
beaucoup à faire ensemble et pour
réussir vous avez besoin de moyens
adaptés
je connais la diversité de vos
territoires et de vos situations
et si certains départements ont une
santé financière satisfaisante à ce jour
c'est loin d'être le cas de tous
votre budget est plus encore que les
autres échelons de collectivité soumis à
un effet de ciseaux
vos marges de manœuvre sur vos dépenses
sont faibles notamment du fait des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
sur lesquels vous n'avez pas la main
[Musique]